[Music]
foreign
Rubin this is the Reuben report it is
March 6
2022 we are live streaming on Rumble you
what
it's 20 20. damn
you see the years going by so fast and I
got the kids down there and the pooping
and the screaming and ah right before
the show I can't believe this I can't
believe it right before the show I said
to the guys as I often do
what do you think what do you think
we're gonna get to today now out of one
to ten obviously ten being the best one
being the worst and I always say you
cannot you can't get a ten a ten it's
just you just can't do it it's like the
NBA dunk contest when they give a guy a
10 it's like no there can never be
anything better I don't accept that to
me a 9 8 is a perfect show right no
coughs no stumbles no errors no sound
issues no nothing just perfection and of
course that the content is going to be
pretty solid now I'm feeling very good
today I'm feeling very sharp and
refreshed I also I have not been in
studio since Wednesday because our
Thursday and Friday shows were pre-taped
because I was in New York uh doing
Gutfeld so I'm feeling very good about
it we do our run through this morning
and you know the run through takes us
about 20 minutes and it's all the clips
making sure everything's in order and
you know feeling good and I'm looking at
all this and I'm going we got a
tremendous show today and also the
content I think is really good today
like I'm really feeling good about this
whole thing and I say to them all right
what do you guys think today Daphne
lowballs me out of nine five and she's
very critical she's very critical but
you have to remember she's you know
she's my assistant she's she makes my
doctor's appointments and things she
knows things so maybe she has some
information uh Phoenix says nine eight
like you're gonna nail it amazing I want
to support you in your mission to do a
good program for the people very
exciting I turned to Connor he doesn't
even give me a number he goes well it's
a dense show
the implication being I could screw up a
whole bunch of things and then I
literally start the show by telling the
wrong year
should we just end the stream now we'll
do this tomorrow
go get lunch
all right let's reset this is a little
nuts here let's just everyone take a sip
of whatever you're sitting there with
it's March 6th 2023 great year very fast
happening Year we're live streaming
right now in the usual spots we've got a
post game show for you at
reubenreport.locals.com and we do have a
tremendous show if you can grant me
just a little bit of a leash on what
just happened with the error related to
the year if you can just give me that I
really think we can pull off a nine
eight here if we just start the grading
now I know that's not how these things
are done we'll have to talk to the
lawyers you know the number crunchers
the accountants Etc but if you can just
from right when I finish this sentence
I'm saying now
we have a tremendous show for you guys
uh if you didn't see it there were so
many break-in Clips over the weekend it
really was nuts I must have sent you how
many things did I send you this weekend
like like 40 things it was really crazy
so the big thing that happened that was
lighting the internet on fire and was so
in line with so much of what we do here
is that Russell's brand you guys know
Russell Brand comedian actor uh he's big
on Rumble of course and and now
political commentator Russell Brand he
went on Real Time with Bill Maher and if
you have not seen these clips he
basically burned down the machine the
corporate media machine the medical
machine like the entire thing so we got
a couple clips of that and then
and this one was so beautiful it was
like handing me the most wonderful gift
and saying take this and enjoy this for
the rest of your life uh crazy socialist
Bernie Sanders was also on real time he
did the private interview at the top of
the show that's just the one-on-one with
Bill and then he joined later on the
panel and it was just incredible Bill
asked him the most basic question ever
related to equity inequality which is
what every Socialist Communist these
collectivists the wokesters this is
their thing that Equity where we finish
is more important than equality where we
begin and Bill gives him the easiest
question in the history of the world for
somebody that has pushed this toxic
ideology on America perhaps more than
anyone and he has no freaking idea yeah
it's just absolutely incredible so
anyway we're framing the show around
those clips and then we've got a whole
bunch of other sort of machine comedians
lying about a bunch of stuff and
basically the whole idea today is how
the machines policies actually cause
serious damage but people are freaking
waking up in droves let the 9 8 begin
all right we start with Real Time with
Bill Maher Friday night uh Russell Brand
was on with MSNBC contributor John
heilman now this guy John Hammond he's
going to be destroyed you're going to
see it it's painful it's watching a man
be burned alive we got a couple clips of
it I don't really mean to make this
about him he's just an MSNBC hack that's
the point he's just a guy who gets up
there note his body language the stumbly
fumbly way he talks versus the just
Clarity and passion of Russell Brand so
this first clip is they're talking about
Fox News and they're all going off on
Fox News and Fox News of course is the
evil punching bag uh and the Boogeyman
for these people because Fox News takes
the counter position of everything else
mainstream MSNBC CNN ABC CBS etc etc
right so it's easy to always go after
Fox they're the only one doing anything
different but Russell who's a lefty he
is a lefty oh and I have him on the show
live in Miami in a couple days uh he is
a lefty he sort of defends that's not
really a defensive Fox but watch how he
turns this on heilman MSNBC and the rest
of it this is beautiful
we
heightened responsibility for our own
perspective I've been on that MSNBC mate
it was propaganda it's not crackery
good morning Joe
Good morning Joe yes
it wasn't morning there was no one
called Joe there no one could
concentrate they didn't understand the
basic tennis of Journalism no one was
willing to stick up for genuine American
Heroes uh like Edward Snowden no one was
willing to talk about Julian Assange and
what he suffered trying to bring real
journalism to the American people and I
think to sit within the castle of MSNBC
throwing rocks at Fox News is ludicrous
my friends make MSNBC make MSNBC great
again my friend I would love I would the
moment
Russell Russell darling
um the moment that you give me a
specific example an actual example
just specific examples
in Europe I'd like to hear a specific
example approval specific example of an
MSNBC correspondent or anchor being on
television saying something they knew
was false and were saying behind the
scenes to his people this is I'm about
to go out and we know that we know that
the election wasn't stolen
but I will go but I will go out but I
will go out on television and say the
opposite I will lie when's my answer
just give me up give me the specific
example give me a specific example all
right I'm with you I think it's a false
equivalency
it's not about bias it's a possible
because you don't actually know anything
about any of these organizations you're
talking about even on MSNBC once big
deal okay we're gonna show you Russell's
answer don't worry but before Russell
gets to his answer if I was sitting
there you've watched this show before
you've heard me go through the litany
the long list of lies that these people
have promoted I scribbled down a few of
the greatest hits while I was watching
this clip once again how about Donald
Trump very fine people on both sides
that he uh did not condemn the neo-nazis
and the white nationalists in
Charlottesville you all know that is a
lie that has been promote voted on MSNBC
relentlessly and in Joe Biden's campaign
launch video he says that moment was
when he decided to run for president uh
we could do masks we could do vaccines
the Covington kids are racist Kyle
Rittenhouse is a white supremacist Brett
Kavanaugh is a serial rapist uh DeSantis
on don't say gay DeSantis on AP
African-American studies I mean we could
go on and on with the things that
they've lied about
Russell responded
do you want an example the ludicrous
outrageous criticisms of Joe Rogan
around Ivermectin who's deliberately
referring to his medicine where they
know it's an effective medicine
if you take this vaccine you're not
gonna get it when it has been clinically
responsible you have to listen wait do
you think you can improve America
and avowedly condemning Fox News without
acknowledging that you're participating
in the same game did you not just listen
to Bernie Sanders someone who plainly
legitimately believes in this country
and believes it's possible to change but
is bound by corruption is bound by the
lobbying system it surely it's clear to
you Bill as one of the great pundits and
experts and comic voices that systemic
changes required money has to be taken
out of politics we need new political
systems that genuinely represent
ordinary Americans so that we can
overcome
differences I'm bickering about which
propagandist network is the worst is not
going to save a single American life not
improve the life of a single American
child not going to approve America's
standing in the world and the world
needs a strong America I'll tell you
that I'll tell you that so you have an
obligation a duty not to condemn these
people and brand is really good and look
I have some differences with them and
I'm going to discuss them with him I
think we're doing it on Wednesday maybe
we'll do it live altogether we were
going to tape it but maybe we'll just
air it live and we'll we'll get audience
questions and a whole bunch more we'll
discuss how we're gonna do that I just
want to jump back to the first clip for
a moment because Bill at one point when
he chimed in he said it was a false
equivalency that Russell was making
meaning that if you that MSNBC is
clearly not as bad as fox now I just
simply don't believe that that is true I
am not defending everything that fox has
done for sure they'd make mistakes
they've they've angled things certain
ways fine I go on there they let me say
whatever I want I never give talking
points I only do interviews live Etc uh
but MSNBC has been far worse because it
is the machine it is always pushing the
machine's lives Fox as a conservative
network is at least slightly taking
another road however to Russell's Point
bickering about which one of them is
worse is actually not going to help
anybody it's why I often say on the show
how much attention should we pay to
MSNBC and CNN and the rest of these
things I think you still it's not
bickering I still think you have to
shine a light on their lies because that
will help wake up people right even
Russell himself who's who's newly I
think sort of red pill to some of this
stuff I think he's realized the Russell
of 2023 is probably very very different
than the Russell of 2018 who probably
bought and swallowed more of those MSNBC
the sort of Lefty lies okay so anyway
when when I saw this clip I was like man
this is this is so perfect on so many
fronts because this is this is so what I
talk about all the time and here you
have a lefty
again he's a Bernie Sanders admirer I
can't stand Bernie Sanders and again I
will get into it with him on that on
Wednesday
um but you have a lefty saying what so
many of us across the political Spectrum
are saying right now and you have them
Bill who's still not quite seeing it but
like man there's a lot here right like
there's there's some richness here so I
watched the clip and then I said to
Phoenix I was like listen why don't we
just grab after he blows up this John
heilman guy why don't we just grab any
compilation clip we've played them a
million times of MSNBC just lying
relentlessly right we've shown you these
clips all the time it doesn't even
matter what they're lying about you guys
got it they're just lying about
everything all the time and then we were
about to grab one of those clips that
we've played before right we've got a
catalog of things that we can just go to
and then of course on Twitter literally
like 20 seconds later I see this clip
from MSNBC over the weekend and there's
at least I counted five lies within a
minute and 10 seconds take a look
our historian's perspective what we're
about to witness is Trump with Trump is
something unprecedented he's still
facing multiple investigations uh as
this 2024 race gets underway so how do
you think
um this plays Into The Narrative of his
uh efforts to become not just the
nominee but the next president of the
United States with all of this legal
baggage hanging over his head we haven't
seen anything like this in history
before
no we have not we haven't seen a
president potentially indicted like this
and it may not be the most physically
fit person of that age that I have ever
seen so you've got that but the even
more dangerous thing Stacy and Michael
is that you know people who try to get a
nomination in parties you know do it by
trying to appeal to what they think will
work well look what Rick DeSantis has
done in Florida he was known as sort of
a nondescript uh political leader member
of Congress suddenly he really has tried
to turn himself into sort of a local
Mussolini in Florida with the book
banding and the brutal tactics and even
this week this suggestion that bloggers
have to register with the state for the
honor of writing about the governor and
other other political leaders we have to
call this what this is this is fascism
and authoritarianism that goes even
beyond what Trump has talked about
that's what he thinks is going to work
in that party and in a way that's the
scariest thing of all I'm running out of
room on my paper for the amount of lies
and distortions there first off the guy
that's hosting that that is Michael
Steele if you do not know him I once
years ago when I was still a lefty and
Michael was on the right he was the
former head of the RNC the Republican
National Committee okay this guy had
huge amount of power and was and what I
would say was a very sane moderate
conservative who at the very very
beginning of the Trump thing was was
explaining to me still a lefty at the
time you can find the interview we did
it live uh on location in Los Angeles
years ago I guess it was 2015 probably
fall of 2015. explaining to me why Trump
made sense and why people were going to
vote for Trump anyway for a couple
hundred thousand bucks which I know is
not nothing he has completely sold his
soul and he's and he hosts a show as a
conservative on MSNBC it's like it's
it's so soulless it's ridiculous but
putting him aside there were many
factual errors in there uh first off he
implies that Donald Trump is not
physically fit to be president we have
no evidence of that there is plenty of
evidence that Joe Biden is not
physically fit he called Ron DeSantis
Rick DeSantis I don't know if that was a
lie or maybe just a mistake he's turning
into Mussolini I would say that's a bit
of a stretch of the truth wouldn't you
uh this thing about registering
reporters that has nothing to do with
DeSantis it's one random congressman and
it's not going to happen but that's just
a moot point uh and then you know he's
basically a fascist and authoritarian
he's actually the reverse of those
things an authoritarian would be locking
their people in their homes and not
letting kids go to school and making
sure that they got injected with
experimental poison and a bunch of stuff
like that he's doing the reverse of
those things oh the book Bannings there
are no book Bannings here I don't know
why it is that that guy by the way that
guy Besh loss I think is his last name
he's a he's a presidential historian so
I don't know why he's giving analysis on
this sort of thing but for some reason
he also seems to want children third
graders to get books about giving
handjobs I don't know you know what
that's that's his thing anyway you see
the within within 10 seconds of playing
the the Russell Brand clip and trying to
figure out okay can we find something
with MSNBC lives or MSNBC distortions or
let's just say swerves around the truth
look how many in just this ridiculously
silly clip anyway then Russell Brand
continued you could see he was like
feeling the Mojo and I think he was
digging in the crowd and the whole
freaking thing and then he just lit a
match and here we go we have a
complicated relationship with the
pharmaceutical industry anybody who's
ever had a uh a family member who's had
cancer
and and seen what uh life-saving drugs
can do for people it also may have given
it to them it may happen but that's
actually kind of my but that's actually
kind of my point is like the the reality
is right like if you have a black and
white point of view the pharmaceutical
industry is engaged in a giant
conspiracy to us all over you are
denying the reality that many people
have lives been saved by those drugs if
you say the pharmaceutical industry has
no has is incapable of error or or
malign Behavior you're equally an idiot
have respect for you in your show I've
bought some facts would you
[Applause]
pandemic created at least 40 new far big
Pharma billionaires pharmaceutical
corporations like moderna and Pfizer
made a thousand dollars of profit every
second from the covid-19 vaccine more
than two-thirds of Congress received
campaign funding from pharmaceutical
companies in the 2020 election Pfizer
chairman Albert baller told Time
magazine in July 2020 that his company
was developing a covered vaccine for the
good of humanity not for money and of
course Pfizer made a hundred billion
dollars in profit in 2022. if you have
an economic system in which
pharmaceutical companies benefit hugely
from medical emergencies where a
military industrial complex benefits
from war where an energy companies
benefit from energy crises you are going
to generate states of Perpetual crisis
for the interests of Ordinary People yes
and separate from the interests of the
elite
yes that is right Russell Brand well
said we will continue that on Wednesday
but you get the point guys like every
now and again a little truth can get
through the machine and he somehow you
know the if you've got a wall here and
there's like this little crack so truth
is just trying to get through like a big
wave is coming and then there's this
wall and it stops this thing it's a dam
but then there's a crack in the dam a
little bit of Truth can leak out to the
other side but he put a freaking serious
serious crack in that thing and a whole
bunch came out on the other side now he
and I have different opinions on what
the role of government is or or can
actually accomplish I think that would
maybe make uh would would in would allow
you to see the difference of opinion in
conclusion that we've come to and that's
fine that's absolutely just fine but he
just told some serious truth there now
let's contrast truth with endless BS
because as I mentioned the other guest
on the show was Bernie Sanders now
Bernie Sanders has been a in essence a
socialist borderline communist I would
say in the United States government for
30 plus years what year did he get into
the Senate it's at least 30 years at
this point
um Bernie other than ushering in uh the
idea that socialism that you should take
from some and give to others and that's
that's how you're nice right that's how
you're a good person which actually that
means you're kind of jealous and you're
not allowed to steal but he other than
pushing that idea on young people he's
accomplished virtually nothing in his
entire career there are no major bills
passed with his name on it there was one
thing related to I think it was like
Vermont uh sanitation or something that
he did like 20 years ago he's
accomplished nothing other than he does
have three houses and he became a
millionaire uh while doing this he was a
first elected into office in
1971 five years before I was born a
senator in 2007 so he was a congressman
first for a while but he's accomplished
a whole bunch of nothing other than push
a lot of bad ideas in this video that
I'm about to show you with Bill Maher is
so unbelievable it should end it it
should all end Bernie should today just
walk into his office and say I'm sorry
guys the two days I spoke like this so
people thought I was nice and my hair
was kind of messy and I was always
saying that rich people are mean so a
bunch of young morons were listening to
me but clearly I don't know what I'm
doing and I'm just going to retire now
I'll move in with John fetterman
wherever he is we'll sit till it'll be
quiet okay just watch this Bernie does
not know the difference between equality
and Equity this is the number one
principle of socialism this is the
number one the top the Pinnacle of this
of at the set of ideas that Bernie
believes in that he has pushed on us
that capitalism is evil that socialism
is good that somehow if you give the
state enough power it can re-jigger
things enough so we all end up the same
and he literally cannot even explain it
but it's not that he can't explain it
you can actually watch his brain explode
at one point I mean this is in freaking
incredible videotape for Quality yeah
it's the same word and it's not the same
word in the same concept so how would
you differentiate between equity and
equality
what equality we talk about uh
I don't know what the answer to that is
told me to think of it you know uh
equality is equality of opportunity all
right we live in a society we want all
people right to have whatever color your
skin is equity I think is more guarantee
of outcome is it none
I think so I think that's okay so which
view come which side do you come down on
all equality equality yeah okay
he literally should have poured gasoline
on his head and burned himself alive
right there that should be the end of it
I know it won't be the end of it but any
sane person if you have any roughly
approximately sane Lefty in your family
and they still think Bernie is good or
Bernie knows what he's talking about
show them that clip he does not know the
basics this is not calculus 704 this is
math 101 and he does not know it when he
just flat out admits I don't know I
don't know and then he explains why
equality is good but he is the one that
has been screaming and dreaming about
social justice and this and that non
Bernie Sanders he is the one that is for
affirmative action which is
state-sponsored discrimination which is
against equality he is the one that has
brought in all of this crazy woke
nonsense right so that we will higher
based on skin color and your genitals
and your perceived gender and all of the
rest of it and he doesn't even know it
and then at the end when Bill tries to
help him right Bill's explaining it oh
you don't you really don't even know
what the basics of your is and then
he basically says he's for equality
it's not us that should be done with
Bernie the all the same people should
have been done with Bernie a long long
time ago the social justice Warriors the
lefties the true socialists you gotta
take him out now right like you guys
have to be done with Bernie Sanders he
is against Equity let's not forget the
day before the last election last
presidential election Kamala Harris put
up a cartoon where she fully admitted
she was a socialist remember that
cartoon we played it here
maybe we'll play it again tomorrow where
she says it's not where we all start
it's where we all end up that we should
all end up equally that is equity and
you're gonna have to hurt a lot of
people because some people are smarter
and some people are work harder and some
people have a little bit more at the
beginning it's true but sometimes
somebody with nothing becomes something
awesome that's the Gestalt of life
that's what it's all about this should
end Bernie but I got plenty more to bury
Bernie let's just bury freaking Bernie
student debt that's another thing he
wants to wipe out student debt because
it's part of social justice because
black lesbians are in debt and we've got
to do something about it Bill Maher
wrecks him on that and Bill by the way
Bill likes birdie Bill's not trying to
wreck him Bill's trying to help him in a
bizarre way but Bernie Sanders
again this is against white people
sometimes I think question some of what
you're saying this is a survey student
loan forgiveness recipient 73 of
applicants say they are likely to spend
their extra money on non-essential
including vacations smartphone drugs and
alcohol they admitted that to the
pollster who is this poster I and this
NBC News
52 they are very likely or likely to buy
new clothing 46 they would use the money
for vacation and eat out at restaurants
this is why people have a thing about I
would never call it free money oh I
guess they just did
bill yeah you're right Bill you've
brought him on many times over the years
to spout his nonsense and and you now as
what I would say is a sane lefty or
realizing that these endless bailouts
just giving people cash but it's not
giving people cash because you have to
take it from other people also we will
soon find out that it is completely
unconstitutional for the government to
just wipe out your debt I have 28 years
more mortgage on this house 30-year loan
I'd prefer not to pay it could someone
do something about that can we get Biden
on the phone can we get that cleared out
what do I need that on the books for
it's it's absolutely incredible so
Bernie doesn't believe in the poll he
also just part of being a socialist is
not understanding anything about basic
human psychology if you give a bunch of
19 year olds cash right you just give
them cash back they could get 100 Grand
back on the debts how much was it I
think it was 100 Grand right it was
going to max out at 100 Grand I think
the the debt for colleges whatever it is
even if it was 10 grand it doesn't it
doesn't even matter what the number is
and by the way whether it was seven
dollars or whether it was a hundred
thousand dollars it would still be
unconstitutional but let's put that
aside for a moment if you just give
people stuff whether it's subsidized
housing or whether it's food stamps
or whether it's cash because they spent
too much to get into a college that they
couldn't afford it doesn't mean that
they're all going to do the right thing
and get and and use that money
effectively most of them probably will
buy weed and they will buy video games
what are the kids playing these days
what Last of Us it's also a television
show thank you that's right up to twenty
thousand dollars by the way was what uh
the Biden Administration was proposing
they are going to use the money on a
whole bunch of stuff but Bernie doesn't
buy that because they don't understand
basic human psychology they just like
the very thin veneer the very thin
veneer is we'd like to help these people
and these people it's I assume it's a
lot of minorities and the lesbians and
the people with one leg and we've got to
help them
but if you don't think that Bernie is a
fraud Beyond human imagination Beyond
imagination who has no balls by the way
Bernie you have no balls either Bernie
from the movie had more balls than you
and he was accomplishing a hell of a lot
more and he was dead weekend at Bernice
you got it you got it everyone got that
okay
um birdie has no balls either because if
he had balls when Hillary Clinton
destroyed him and he and he actually had
the movement of the Democrat Party as
backwards and ridiculous as I think that
movement is he should have launched a
campaign against her right he should
have gone off and created a third party
that was his moment but he didn't he
backed her and now he's just on his
descent to nothingness but on the way to
his descent to nothingness he's also
really into war so that's fun for the
Socialists enjoy should America send
f-16s it's not an issue that I've been
heavily involved in but I I support what
the president is doing I think what
Putin did was outrageous
not only for the people of the Ukraine
and all the destruction not only for the
thousands and tens of thousands of
Russian soldiers who have been dying we
need a world now if we're going to come
back climate change if we're going to
come back future pandemics we need a
world to come together and Putin has
radically disrupted that and that is a
real tragedy but I think at the end of
the day the United States NATO cannot
sit back and allow Putin's aggression to
go uh unresponded guys I don't know if
you know this but I'm not a lefty has
anyone ever made note of that
um I was a lefty but I'm not a lefty
anymore but if I was a lefty I would be
so pissed at that fraud like I'm not
pissed at him now like I'm rather
emotive today
it's true I think I've had a lot of
coffee
um but I'm not pissed at him like he's
just showing me what he is but if I was
a lefty if I had been a believer in a
Bernie bro a believer in all of this
socialist nonsense and the power to the
people and all of this stuff that all
sounds good but never works in socialism
and collectivism always kill couple
hundred million people and blah blah
blah never accomplishes anything and I
know the social so we say well we've
never done it exactly right yet the
thing is we just haven't had a chance
the idea that Bernie first off he hasn't
been heavily involved in the war that's
funny because Bernie's very concerned
about money right he always wants money
so he can do what he wants not his money
he wants to take someone else's money
it's always those rich mean billionaires
who usually create a lot of stuff and a
lot of jobs and industries and all that
you want to take their money and he
wants to give it to other people in this
case where we've given Ukraine I think
now we're over 120 billion dollars uh
he's not that interested in this this
isn't something he's paid much attention
to right he doesn't pay much attention
to that he's mostly focused on whether
Starbucks workers in Boston will be able
to unionize that's really where he's
focused not on the 120 billion but
besides that uh he really uh they're
somehow I mean it's just so incredible
what they do somehow he linked we must
stop Russia so that we can all work
together on climate change and future
pandemics what planet is this old
socialist buffoon on I don't know I
genuinely do not know but
congratulations like if you've been a
Bernie supporter this is your moment you
can now realize that the king of your
socialist movement who by the way was
going to be destroyed I mean the whole
purpose of these movements is to eat the
revolutionaries right so Bernie at the
end it was always going to end poorly
for him because at the end he was just
an old white guy who became a
millionaire somehow even though he's
been in government since 1971 as a
socialist somehow became a millionaire
with three houses right
um but he was always going to end poorly
for him because he was going to be an
old white guy at the end and the and the
radicals and the BLM people in the
walksters of course they were going to
take him out so Bernie you're on your
way out dude the machine is just about
done with you and and that Equity versus
equality thing
I mean that would literally be like
asking LeBron James do you know the
difference between a free throw and a
three-pointer and him being like
I don't how many dribbles before you
travel like it it's so incredible it's
just absolutely amazing but let's
continue because the machine you guys
know about the machine and I love the
fact oh one other thing on the Russell
Brand thing first off I love the fact
that he was talking about the machine
right because it's this it's this
amorphous hard to describe thing that
seemingly is in front of us all the time
so we have to respond to it all the time
but the other thing that I loved is he
brought receipts what do I always say
bring receipts to these shows what did
Ted Cruz do on The View that day when
they asked him about election denialism
and Donald Trump and the Maga the Ultra
Mega Republicans they deny elections and
Ted Cruz well speaking of denying
election that the Hillary Clinton and
Stacy Abrams
so the fact that he did that was
prepared and ready to roll and one of
the reasons that this heilman guy
and whose body language was just
terrible at his sort of stammering
condescending way of speaking to him one
of the reasons that he can't back
anything up is they're not used to
having to make an argument because they
go on these ridiculous shows and they
they get puffed up with no pushback
right uh we'll get to plenty more on
that in just a second so uh let's just
talk a little bit more about the machine
because one of the guys that I always
talk to you is just like a front end
facing just sort of soulless version of
what the machine chokes out is Jimmy
Kimmel Jimmy Kimmel who has been in
blackface many times his former
girlfriend ex-girlfriend Sarah Silverman
has also been in blackface but the the
Hollywood portion of the machine is very
important because there's a political
version of the machine right that's
always pushing big government the
Hollywood portion is always pushing all
of the bad ideas so that they can win
the culture wars so basically people
will be stupid enough to believe in the
political version of it anyway here's
Jimmy Kimmel who has gotten everything
wrong related to kovid who has called
everybody racist who is you know again
he's in blackface the whole thing uh
here he is mocking Aaron Rodgers you
guys know quarterback Aaron Rodgers
because Aaron Rodgers is kind of
interested in who Jeffrey Epstein was uh
you know getting those chicks for but
somehow Jimmy Kimmel decided that that's
worthy of joking about
needless to say all this UFO talk has
the tinfoil Hatters going wild including
Green Bay whack Packer Aaron Rodgers who
offered this hot take on the Pat McAfee
show I I believe that this has been
going on for a long time
interesting uh timing on everything
there's a lot of other things going on
in the world did you hear about the
Epstein Client List about to be released
too what's that what are you talking
about
there's some files that have have some
names on it that might be uh getting
released pretty soon oh
oh
might be time to revisit that concussion
protocol Aaron that's
what
first off Jeffrey Epstein who died in
jail
um die to jail somehow the cameras went
off remember it was very bizarre the
cameras went off died in jail uh then he
has his sidekick Gisele Maxwell right
and she's still in jail right now but
they were both in jail for basically
trafficking young women to all of these
people and we've all seen the videos of
Epstein Island and the flights with Bill
Clinton and all these other world
leaders and everything else now I don't
I have no idea more than you do as to
what the real truth around this thing is
but it seems a little bizarre that the
guy who's in sort of in charge of the
whole operation he dies in jail the
cameras go out okay fine The Other Woman
ends up in jail why wouldn't you want to
know The Client List why would you oh
why would the only people who should pay
for trafficking young children so raping
young children the only people who
should pay for that are the two people
who did the trafficking what about all
the people who did the I'm gonna we're
gonna get the they should
probably be in trouble too right so why
is it why would Jimmy Kimmel choose why
would or the machine that's in charge of
Jimmy Kimmel why would it choose to even
bring that up to mock the people who are
putting attention on it right it's the
tin foil what what tin foil hat are you
talking about man it is completely legit
to be like oh someone went to jail
because they helped a whole bunch of
people rape a bunch of children maybe we
should find out who those people are I
don't even know what the conspiracy he's
talking about is
but watch this so then he continues the
guys the guy's Hanging On by a thread I
mean all these people and the thing is
once the machine's done with you it's
just done with you so you'll get your
cash Kimmel like I you have way more
money than me good for you like you're
gonna get your cash and your payouts and
all that stuff and then and then the
machine will be done with you one day
it's like it's the stelter thing it's
the Don Lemon thing you give it what it
wants and then one day it wants
something else but it's too late for you
because you've already sold your soul to
it it might be a clear today have I made
my feelings clear today here's Jimmy
Kimmel going after Tucker but the whole
thing turns out to be just a giant cell
phone watch this one
speaking of diarrhea Tucker Carlson of
Fox News
yesterday
we learned that the um the department of
energy you probably know about this
believes with what they described as low
confidence that covid may have leaked
from a lab in China eight federal
agencies now have weighed in with their
assessments four believe covet came from
natural transmission to say it was a lab
leak and two are still on the side in
other words we don't know but the
dingbats now see this as some kind of
proof that they were right that the
virus came from a Chinese leak at a
laboratory which by the way it might
have the point is we didn't know then we
still don't know now but what we did
know is that Trump and his buddies
blaming the Chinese resulted in a great
deal of anti-asian American sentiment
and even violence in this country and
that's why it was irresponsible for the
president to call it the China virus but
Tucker Carlson apparently disagrees this
plague should never have happened it
could have been stopped
but people chose not to stop it what
people tomorrow he'll blame the Spanish
Flu on Antonio Banderas
yeah
imagine if you're a comedian and all of
a sudden your cue card has all kinds of
talking points from politicians and
foreign governments on it
don't read it you degrade yourself and
you become complicit in the greatest
crime in history isn't that beautiful I
mean the idea that this man would accuse
that I would be accused of reading
talking points from foreign governments
if it weren't so Brazen it would almost
be funny coming from this loathsome
Un-American Moscow mule
speaking of almost funny Jimmy you're
nowhere close to it you're just not in
there at all there's a whole bunch there
that that's worth dissecting but without
uh belaboring the point uh even within
his attack on Tucker there uh he's lying
and of course he's lying about Trump
right so Trump trump called it the China
virus and said that it probably came
from the Wuhan lab leak right now we
this increasingly is becoming more
obvious to most of us I do not know for
a hundred percent okay and nor do you
but the fact that for two years you
would have been kicked off Twitter or
Facebook for even questioning it is
fairly interesting and then the way the
machine operates you all know this we
played the clip last week Jon Stewart
then about a year and a half ago roughly
a year ago or so he goes on Stephen
Colbert another Machine Show and he says
Wuhan labley and then suddenly everyone
was allowed to talk about it before that
you would get booted off all of the
things that's partly I don't know
exactly how it all works but that's
partly how the machine stays in front
all the time right because it as these
These Walls these firewalls of what is
allowed to get out and when is when it's
allowed to get out but Kimmel even lies
within that because he says that somehow
there was this spike in anti-asian
sentiment because Donald Trump said that
it was the the Wuhan it was the China
flu something like that it's really
interesting because there has been a
spike in anti-asian hate crimes
virtually all like 99.9 of them have
been from young black men so am I to
believe in and they're happening in
Philadelphia and it's happening in New
York City in Los Angeles and elsewhere
and you've all seen the videos of I mean
just horrific videos people going into
little mom and pop shops and beating the
crap out of people shooting people
attacking old women on the street all of
this stuff right it was happening we've
seen two years of this so he is right
about that but am I to Believe Jimmy
Kimmel that somehow Donald Trump who you
think is a white supremacist was
signaling to young black men that their
white supremacist leader wanted them to
attack Asian people because of what he
said about China which is the place that
the virus likely came from it's just
absolutely incredible so you might be
saying to yourself so why is it that
someone like Jimmy Kimmel
pays service to the machine so much why
does he become an absolute hack I don't
know Tucker is implying that he's
getting messaging from a foreign
government I don't know that but I know
that there's a giant Corporation
involved that keeps Jimmy Kimmel on air
to lie about basically all of America
and to constantly play up whatever it is
they want him to play up so why is it
that he would do that now it is it is
cash right everyone's got a number right
and I don't like impuning motives in
such a way but at some level like if
people were going to pay you let's say I
don't know what does Jimmy Kimmel make
per year can we get a number on that I'm
guessing it's probably about 15 million
a year and and with you think of all the
other ancillary ways he makes money it's
probably a lot more than that 15
literally I was just making that up all
right 15 a year anyone in here making 15
million a year okay nobody in this room
is making 15 million a year but the
point is there's a price on everybody's
head but there's something else going on
here and the other thing that the
machine loves is having something to
hold over these people because then you
can get them to basically do anything so
Jimmy Kimmel who has been a Prime
purveyor of cancel culture and that he
calls everyone racist and bigots and
homophobes and all those things and he's
going out of his way as part of the
machine to always go after Tucker
Carlson because he would love Tucker
Carlson to be taken out right like that
is the truth Tucker would as Tucker is
the number one show in the history of
late night he has no need to go after
Jimmy Kimmel but Jimmy Kimmel is always
going after him right so then it becomes
a little bit of like a rap War like
rappers that hate each other they go
after each other it's kind of net good
for everybody but there's something else
with Jimmy Kimmel the thing is that
Jimmy Kimmel hosted a show called The
Man Show and on that show with my buddy
his co-host was my buddy Adam Carolla I
didn't know Adam at the time we've since
become friends Adam Carolla is still a
funny comedian a politically incorrect
actually funny comedian but you're not
going to believe this guys they used to
make jokes about gay people on that show
and about women and sometimes midgets
like everything so you think maybe Jimmy
Kimmel's playing along to the machine
because the machine doesn't want you to
see things like this because then he
might get canceled and that would be a
big shame because Jimmy Kimmel want his
15 million dollars
tell us what you think of the statue
I mean do you think that she's do you
think that I mean do you think that
she's attractive or not
take another look at it
[Music]
foreign
you know when I went back a couple weeks
ago for uh the prageru thing uh I did
have I had a nice Italian meal at a
place something wolf mother wolf or
something really nice pasta over there
the meatballs were delicious but I'm
pretty sure I can never go back but
anyway these these comedians comedians
are supposed to fight the power
comedians are supposed to tell you
something true but you can see what
Jimmy Kimmel is doing there he has to
atone for his past sins by by praying to
their modern golden calf right and he's
not the only one Jon Stewart and this
one's kind of disappointing I I interned
at The Daily Show in 1999 I had a couple
decent interactions with Jon Stewart Jon
Stewart although I think in his heart of
hearts he's probably just a decent
liberal but he has been whacked out and
broken by by the woke machine and here
he is relentlessly and and in the most
smug I mean watch this I could not be
this smug if I try in the most smug
condescending tone going after an
Oklahoma state senator his name is
Nathan Dom I don't know why he agreed to
do this show like you got to know you're
being set up the entire time but John
thinks that drag shows for kids are very
very important we've got to support drag
shows for kids I'm going to go out on a
limb here Jon Stewart if you're watching
you've never taken your kid to a drag
show and I'm pretty sure that I don't
know if you have sons or daughters but
I'm pretty sure if your son came home
and said he was a girl you'd be pretty
pissed about it but somehow you think
that drag shows for kids are great and
you got to mock the people who are
trying to do something about it you want
to ban drag show readings to children
tomorrow yes why why why what are you
protecting why can we prohibit children
from voting those under 18 from votes
why are you Banning that is is that free
speech are you infringing on that
performer's Free Speech they can
continue to exercise their free speech
just not in front of a child why because
the government does have a
responsibility to protect I'm sorry the
government does have a responsibility in
certain systems the leading cause of
death amongst children in this country
and I'm going to give you a hint it's
not drag show readings to Children
correct yes
so what is it I'm presuming you're going
to say it's Firearms no I'm not going to
say it like it's an opinion that's what
it is it's Firearms more than cancer
more than car accidents and what you're
telling me is you don't mind infringing
free speech to protect children from
this amorphous thing that you think of
but when it comes to children that have
died you don't give a flying
to stop that because that shall not be
infringed that is hypocrisy at its
highest order
John you are a hack at the highest order
like he's unbearable I don't even know
what to say about him I think Jimmy
Kimmel might be more likable than Jon
Stewart at this point first off the guy
should not have gone on the show no one
should be falling for these things
anymore right like it's it's so obvious
uh but you know John uh infringing on
someone's rights related to drag shows
and and kids do you think it's okay to
show porn to children
like obviously you don't so this isn't
purely a First Amendment Free Speech
issue the government unless you're an
anarchist I guess maybe you're a
complete Anarchist John and you believe
that the government has no role no
responsibility when it comes to
absolutely anything but as I often say
about this drag show children thing why
is it that they simply want to do this
for kids why is it that drag shows are
not happening at the annual actuary
conference we know that actuaries love
having a good time just ask the
accountants okay why is it at the
national shoe salesman event you know
they don't have the drag queens right
they only want to do this for kids and
why does he feel the need to defend it
no one's defending children getting shot
and we can all have a debate about how
we would stop doing that now John of
course because he's a lefty and part of
the machine his answer would always be
to take the guns but of course you know
generally good people with guns don't
shoot a whole bunch of people that's how
it works I thought we'd just give you a
little bit more information on on gun
deaths just because we've gone this far
here's uh some info from the New England
Journal of Medicine medicine uh the CDC
recently released updated official
mortality data showed that 45 222
firearm related deaths in the U.S in
2020 a new Peak these new data show a
sharp 13.5 percent increase in the crude
rate of firearm related deaths from 2019
to 2020. this change was driven largely
by firearm homicides which saw 33.4
increase in the crude rate from 2019 to
2020 whereas the crude rate of firearm
suicides increased by 1.1 percent from
2019 to 2020 the relative increase in
the rate of firearm related deaths of
all type suicide homicide unintentional
and undetermined among Children and
adolescents was at 29.5 five percent
more than twice as high as the relative
increase in the general population I'll
get into why I'm explaining all this in
just a moment in addition drug overdose
and poisoning increased by 83.6 from
2019 to 2020 among Children and
adolescents becoming the third leading
cause of death in that age group this
change is largely explained by the
hundred ten percent increase in
unintentional poisonings from 2019 to
2020. let's just show you a chart here
as well
uh leading cause of death among children
and adolescents in the U.S from 1999 to
2020 was motor vehicle car crashes 1999
to 2020. interesting what happened in
2020 these crashes have been declining
dramatically over the past 20 years
firearm related injuries were also
declining until 2013 when they steadily
began to rise and then it spiked in 2020
so why is there some weird aberration in
2020 do you think it has something to do
with keeping kids at home and school
lockdowns and making them afraid of the
climate and viruses and then sending
them out to Riot and not having an
honest discussion about crime and
domestic violence and child abuse and
drugs and then also the Doom scrolling
on Twitter and what the algorithms are
doing to manipulate everybody so I am
not saying there isn't any issue at all
related to I we'd all like less children
to be killed by guns for sure but the
ant if you think the answer is the
government should just come in and take
them but okay the gun thing is a
completely separate issue the point is
why is John paying service to the
machine to go out there to defend drag
queens for children why I would ask you
that question like what is the answer
what is the answer and then just like
you know I'm telling you guys I I have
done some version of this show now for
like eight years interviewing people
telling people what I think everything
else like the idea that I would ever sit
with someone and be so smug and
condescending to them even if I had AOC
on let's say I had like the worst of the
worst if I had Bernie Sanders sitting
across from me or I had AOC or ilhan
Omar any of the people that
ideologically I'm completely uh opposite
of if I had any of them sitting across
from me the truth is the real truth and
I and I I certainly hope you would
believe me on this is that I would treat
them the same way I treat every other
guest I have had plenty of guests on who
I did not agree on certain things I have
had Ben Shapiro on making his religious
case against same-sex marriage and we
treated each other with respect okay I
have debated abortion with plenty of
people I have debated death penalty with
plenty of people
taxes all of the things I can sit across
from someone and treat them respectfully
the smug condescend condescension that
only a television Hollywood liberal
could have at that perfect that perfect
pitch that John does it with it's just I
can't believe it I cannot believe I'm
saying he's he's worse than Jimmy Kimmel
it's absolutely incredible but all right
let's find some other terrible people to
talk about uh our press secretary who is
one of many LGBT members of the
administration we have more women and
gays and we got the whole thing than any
other Administration or any of them
qualified doesn't matter doesn't matter
can any of these people get anything
done does our transportation secretary
know about Transportation who cares he's
gay
anyway here's uh Karen Jean-Pierre
slamming Tennessee governor Bill Lee
because he's signing a law that will
restrict children's drag shows now again
they're not arresting drag queens they
are not saying drag queens you cannot do
your drag shows at late night bars where
you always have done them or at other
events for adults we would just prefer
you don't do these things for children
because it's obviously a very
hyper-sexualized event
and this is something that shouldn't be
out there for kids like any sane person
agreed on this 10 years ago anybody but
now the entire machine is going after
anyone who dares to speak out against it
take a look right now you have a
governor from Tennessee as this decided
to go after drag shows what sense does
that make to go after drag shows how
does that going to help people's lives
who are thinking about the economy who
are thinking about making sure their
kids are going are going to be safe when
they go to school their communities are
safe but that's what he wants to focus
on so it's part of a larger pattern from
elected officials who espouse freedom
and liberty but apparently think that
freedom of speech only extends to people
who agree with them and that's what
we're seeing from what's happening in
Tennessee and other places as well I'm
telling you guys these people are all so
deep in the lies they cannot say
anything true Karin Jean-Pierre much
like John Saki and so many of these
other people they simply cannot utter
one complete sentence that is true all
the conservatives whatever you want to
call it are doing
are just saying enough is enough you
guys will not stop you are a rebel force
that will not stop and enough people are
saying hey can we just go back to
something that was semi-sane of 10 years
ago no one in their right mind
would have said it is okay
I I've been a couple times over the
years to drag shows first off I never
found them funny or interesting because
most of them are just kind of hacky
comedians making disgusting sexual jokes
now I don't know that all of them are
doing that at these kids things but no
one is coming for anyone's Free Speech
go be a drag queen say whatever you want
but just not in front of children that's
all that some of the states are doing
and I love how she somehow confuses this
and well you know these they're just
regular people out there who want their
children to be safe yeah no
Sherlock but note the overly emotional
way that they do absolutely everything
remember that video that we showed you
last week of the teachers union
president Randy Weingarten and she was
standing in front of the Supreme Court
and she was very upset that the Supreme
Court might not do what she wants she
wants debt to be wiped out because she
needs the money to keep rolling in for
the the public schools and all those
things because she's got a very cushy
job and somehow she's always in Ukraine
hanging out it's all very bizarre
but what did she do she gets up there
and she starts screaming and she's bad
her arms are flying all over the place
and where
she does all that and then it's a it's
like a certain amount of people watch it
and they go oh she's very emotional so
she must be right that's what the left
is really mastered oh they're always
screaming about things so they must be
right because how else could you be so
emotional that time it's like a base
level psychological trick anyway here is
uh
here we have a warning for the good
people
yeah the view we got to show you the
view here's Whoopi who once again just
want to say loved her and ghost Molly
you in danger girl but Whoopi has lost
she has smoking too much weed I've heard
from insiders by the way that she shows
up every day baked that's what I've just
heard I'm just saying just heard anyway
uh here she is and just yeah it's us
it's us that are the problem not
walksters okay go whoopee this idea of
what I'm going to say it again
most of y'all were asleep
who are you speaking speaking to I'm
talking about all those folks that use
that word woke all the time y'all were
asleep
we were never asleep we had to stay
awake watching you okay so you woke up
and you thought oh my God there's
there's lots of women running among
doing things they're not supposed to be
doing and drag queens everywhere and oh
my God people of color you know you
always talk about
the snowflakes look in the mirror y'all
can't seem to handle anything you can't
seem to handle competition from from
Democrats to Republicans you can't seem
to handle the discussions of why people
feel the way they do your idea is to get
rid of everything so stop calling us
snowflakes
be nice Dave try to be nice all right do
I even have to like comment on that like
you guys have been have started a war a
war for children's minds and their
bodies you've tried to racialize
everything you want five-year-olds
watching Disney shows that will teach
white people white kids to be guilty by
the color of their skin you guys have
done this now finally
finally and we have to give Donald Trump
some credit for this Donald Trump broke
the thing so people started seeing it
and then other people culturally and
politically people start getting
involved and start pushing back that's
all they're doing that's all any of us
are doing and you might go well but Dave
maybe maybe you're being a little over
the top here maybe wokeness isn't that
bad maybe there aren't a set of people
who are truly brainwashed by all of this
nonsense well clay Travis found this
online I thought this was incredible
this is the front page of the New York
Times over the weekend this is a front
page article black equestrians plead for
helmets that fit and look at that girl
there that apparently that's a black
girl she looks white to me but I'll I'll
go with it okay maybe maybe the ink on
that particular copy was off a little
bit but she has giant dreadlocks which I
assume is some sort of cultural
appropriation of predator or something
like that and the entire article guy is
she's upset that her dreadlocks don't
fit into most helmets that people wear
while riding horses and that thus is
proving what a racist Nation we are and
then the coffee drinking Sunday New York
Times liberal reads it and like my God
darling did you hear this this is
absolutely extraordinary there's a black
woman who has dreadlocks and that coffee
is good what's that what's that kind of
latte was that was that over 12 well
however much money it costs is worth it
but can you believe this this is
systemic racism darling this is this
poor woman who has many horses and who
rides around who seems to be doing quite
well I don't know how despite the
systemic uh you know discrimination and
racism of this country and she's also on
the front page of the New York Times she
needs a bigger helmet is there something
we can do darling no no no no not give
our own Money Can't We complain about it
to somebody who might do something else
about it I don't what accent is that
I turned them in that was more of like a
British aristocracy accent but like I
think you get the point I don't like
these people I don't like their accents
okay anyway
uh it all continues it all continues
because once you buy into the woke thing
and boys are girls and racism is good
especially if it's against white people
and all those things you will ultimately
degrade the entire system because you
will not have a meritocracy you will not
have a system where through competition
and hard work and human Ingenuity a
whole group of people are going to bust
their butts and go man there's something
I want out there and I'm gonna go get it
and I'm gonna be the best at what I can
do that is what this nation was built on
that's why your ancestors came here
meritocracy it's good it is good
competition it's good these people don't
want it because they are they love the
idea of a system that can control
everybody but affirmative action fits
right within this if you say well okay
we'd like to help a certain set of
people
what you are going to have to do is
discriminate against another set of
people and then you say okay well these
people can get into a school in an
easier way and in grad school in an
easier way and a job in an easier way at
some point whatever job you're trying to
put them into whatever it is that you're
whatever you're trying to get them into
be it an airline pilot or a heart
surgeon you're going to have lower
quality people because the top the
number one thing when hiring for an
important job would be the highest
qualification so you wouldn't want to
look at someone's genitals
board anyway this is just incredible
watch this so uh this is North Carolina
Senator Ted Budd and he is asking a uh a
nominee to be FAA administrators last
name's Washington
um which probably is racist but he's
black so what are you gonna do about FAA
policy now if you wanted to be the FAA
administrator you know I'm not a uh you
know I'm not an expert in avionics or
whatever but if you wanted to be in
charge of the FAA you'd have to know a
lot about flying I would imagine policy
related to flying things of that nature
uh so they have these hearings because
they want to know that this guy's
qualified for the job this is absolutely
extraordinary the man wants to be the
FAA administrator watch these questions
from Ted bud and you tell me if this guy
should get the job so Mr Washington can
you quickly tell me what airspace
requires an adsb transponder not sure I
can answer that question right now
that's okay we'll just keep going so um
that's a that's a pretty and
important part so what are the six types
of special use airspace
that protect this National Security that
appear on FAA charts uh sorry Senator I
cannot answer that question okay so what
are the operational limitations of a
pilot flying under basic Med Senator I'm
not a pilot so obviously you'd ever see
that Federal Aviation Administration so
um any idea what those restrictions are
under basic Med quickly
well some of the restrictions I think
would be high blood pressure some of
them would be it's more like how many
passengers per airplane how many pounds
in different categories and uh what else
what uh altitude uh you can fly under so
and uh and then
uh amount of knots it's under 250 knots
so it's not having anything to do with
blood pressure so can you tell me what
causes an aircraft to spin or to stall
again Senator I'm not a pilot
um okay uh let's keep going what are the
three aircraft certifications FAA
requires as part of the manufacturing
process quickly please
three aircraft certifications
again uh what I would say to that is
that one of my first priorities would be
to fully Implement that certification
act uh and Report you know the three
types Mr Washington the three types okay
he's gonna get the job like he's gonna
get the job I'm telling you I'm gonna
learn how to fly a plane that's it I'm
getting my pilot's license I'm not
kidding I've said to you a couple times
on the show my goal really I don't want
any I have everything I want I truly
mean that I have everything in this
world that I want
but I I do want to fly my own plane now
okay well I want to fly private would be
ideal I just don't have a lot of time to
be learning how to fly but it does seem
kind of cool to learn how to fly like
how if they're going to hire more and
more of these people in all of our
professional positions do you wonder why
everything seems like it doesn't work
anymore why it's always harder to get
people qualified to do anything no one
knows how to do anything because once
you let wokeness in and this is what you
must understand would be once you say to
people we should focus on your genitals
and your skin color then everything else
whatever the mission statement of the
organization or the non-profit or the
political machine or the school or
whatever it is once you put some other
thing we should focus on this over here
instead of the thing you are going to
slowly destroy the thing and we're going
to have literal planes falling out of
the sky because we're going to have
unqualified people flying them but at
least the plane will have all its
diversity checks off it it's just
completely ridiculous and with and I'm
just gonna say it because you losers at
Media Matters are always watching the
show uh this is not to be discriminatory
against anyone I'm trying to be
anti-discriminatory I don't care if my
pilot is black or gay or a lesbian or
whatever
I just want them to be freaking
qualified okay let's continue because
this government is not interested in
doing anything that a qualified set of
people would be doing here's Karin
Jean-Pierre again and now remember Karin
John Pierre black lesbian I don't care
about that really that's wonderful that
she's a black lesbian spectacular
really fantastic you've got another word
for a black lesbian
super what fabulous awesome great
um but here she is she's just
unqualified for her job which is why she
always is bringing up the fact that
she's a black lesbian because she's not
qualified to do what she's doing
here she is saying that 173 house
Democrats have backed a whole bunch of
new laws and you tell me if anything she
says here seems good to you I did talk
to the team and we have a couple of
things that I just want to lay out for
all of you and on what the DC Bill does
it reduces maximum penalties for
offenses like murders and other
homicides armed home invasion burglaries
armed armed carjackings as I mentioned
armed robberies unlawful gun possession
and some sexual assault offenses guys
this is so freaking awesome did you
catch what she's doing
173 Democrats they want to reduce
penalties for murders carjackings armed
robberies armed home assault and sexual
assault
great and you wonder why people are
fleeing blue states and cities in droves
now you may remember last week we showed
you a clip of Kevin O'Leary Kevin
O'Leary is Mr Wonderful from Shark Tank
he was being interviewed uh we showed
you a couple clips of it being
interviewed by Tucker Carlson and he's
making the rounds and and Kevin O'Leary
from where I sit is a pretty sane cogent
guy who was an accomplished an awful lot
he has invested millions and millions if
not hundreds of millions of dollars into
all sorts of companies some of them
succeed some of them fail again that's
what it's all about competition
meritocracy try to make something create
something someone else create something
you got to make a better mouse trap it's
all beautiful it's what America is all
about it's what the human spirit is all
about uh he now has had it basically
with everything coming out of the
Democrat Party The Machine the left the
progressives all of that stuff and he's
acknowledging that it's actually
destroying the blue States here he is
talking about New York and what AOC and
her ridiculous so socialist policies
have done to New York and you're not
going to believe this if you watch the
end of this thing Don Lemon
I don't know how this happened this is a
bizarre day Don Lemon kind of agreed
with something that made sense what is
going on is there tequila in my coffee
thousands of jobs coming out of that I
mean that is that's New York
uninvestable sorry don't shoot the
messenger just telling you the way it is
yes
some pushback from our our elected
officials in New York and that's going
to say Kathy hokels yeah but we'll
debate them any time of the day you want
we would love to discover the AOC snap
she's great at killing jobs she kills
jobs by that thousands you know another
New Jersey problem
where did Amazon take their jobs they
took them away from her she threatened
to sue them if they created jobs I mean
this is a reality there's a reality that
there's a little more to it but let's
not really well sorry it just telling
the truth he's saying what a lot of
people are saying especially what
happened with that Amazon thing here in
New York just lemon getting one right at
the end there absolutely incredible it
must have been opposite day you could
see the way the other anchors look they
want to act as the litigators as the
lawyers for the Democrat policies right
and of course what he said what Mr
Wonderful said was I'll debate her I'll
debate hoko I'll debate AOC on this
stuff any day little just side anecdote
about what happened there with the AOC
Amazon thing you may remember Amazon was
going to bring a massive massive factory
to New York it was it was actually about
uh 10 or 15 miles from my parents house
the house that I grew up in that my
parents are still at now for those few
weeks when that when it looked like it
was going to happen house prices in the
area spiked because they were going to
bring in something like 10 000 I think
it might have even been more it doesn't
even matter what the exact amount number
is thousands of and thousands of new
jobs and what comes with new jobs is new
people moving into the community and
then you know what new people need they
need homes to live in so house prices in
my parents neighborhood were jumping
because they were going to have
competition on houses and then people
would have competed on house prices and
it would have been good for everybody
somebody that lived in say an
economically depressed area now Amazon
comes in holy cow we have a Starbucks on
our corner and the house prices are
going up and you're not going to believe
it now there's more tax money to go to
the system and their hot diggity dog
they're Paving the roads isn't that wild
but AOC killed the freaking thing and
she did it in the name of social justice
because we Must Destroy Amazon I have my
issues with Amazon I try not to use
Amazon as much as possible we do use it
I'm not gonna lie right we have kids
here I got two young kids there's a lot
of stuff we need and some of it you need
really quick and Amazon can get it to
you quick but I try as much as possible
not to but I don't go out of my way to
destroy the company thinking that I'm
doing something good while really all
I'm doing is hurting the average guy
who's going to get a decent paying job
and then be able to move into a nice
house openly and everything else anyway
O'Leary continued just to decimate the
blue States and it is just obvious and
true and real and I know you know it but
it's nice that it's making its way to
CNN
the state where I grew my kids I mean
our family grew up in Boston
Massachusetts we left there to move to
Florida like everybody else's because
it's such a tough place to you know this
is a tough message people really are
critical about this but somebody has to
call it out because this is a
competition of States now and we don't
put money there anymore we put it in
other places and jobs are created
elsewhere over time this is going to
diminish New Jersey diminish New York
diminish Massachusetts and California
out of business out of business El morte
no business there you can't do business
there I don't know what that's the place
is going to turn into maybe a tourist
Zone but no business imagine San
Francisco you can't even walk at night
out in the street
what's happened you can't even walk
during the day on the street in San
Francisco but he's right everyone knows
it and again you don't have to even dive
into all of the numbers about economics
and crime and everything else you would
simply just have to look at which way
people are moving is there a mass Exodus
from Texas and Florida or a mass influx
of people I think you know the answer
but then we saw this this is from CBS
News covering the mass Exodus from
California but watch the way the machine
frames this everyone knows including the
people that are sitting in this room
with me and all of the people I moved
with two companies and everyone I meet
in Florida every single freaking day
when I'm at the supermarket wherever I
am all of these refugees that come here
and no one ever ever I kid you not no
one has ever said to me I moved here
because of the taxes meaning that we
don't have income tax here in Florida
and it's high in California people knew
what they were paying in California but
you sort of did it you were close to
Malibu maybe you like own a wine country
okay La Hollywood there was something
cool about it maybe 10 years ago no one
that everyone that I meet here they say
the same thing well it was the crime it
was the drugs I wanted to be free I
didn't want to force my kids to be
masked and vax and everything else and
then what almost everyone says right
after that is and then the tax thing is
kind of nice and I think that's the way
I framed it a million times the fact
that I'm saving money to be here is
completely bananas I would have paid
money to get it DeSantis if you're
watching I think we should start
charging people on Entry tax anyway
watch the way CBS News covers the mass
Exodus out of California and tell me if
you think this is uh relatively honest
and connecting to all of the things that
we all know
Americans are leaving California and New
York in droves new Census Data revealed
half a million people left California
during the covet pandemic cbs's Joy
Benedict joins me now to explain the
reason behind the mass Exodus good
evening Joy
good evening jarika that's right believe
it or not as you mentioned folks are
packing up they are leaving making these
big moves saying goodbye to cities like
here in Los Angeles New York and Chicago
and the main reason why is money
Californians are loading up and moving
out
as the appeal of the Golden State seems
to be tarnishing at least for some it's
just not sustainable in terms of cost of
living Preston Lee is leaving Los
Angeles for Austin Texas it's
incomparable the house that we bought
was 700 000 for four bedroom four and a
half bathroom four thousand square feet
can't get an apartment for that here
more people are exiting California than
any other state New York is second many
of those leaving are now calling Florida
and Texas Home kefir Cohen owns a moving
company how much more business have you
seen I would say there was a growth of
almost 100 percent so it's our job was
like almost double itself
I kid you not I didn't realize this when
I saw the clip earlier I think that's
the guy that I used to move I'm not
kidding I think I've had conversations
with that guy anyway or maybe we we
negotiated with him or something it
definitely looks familiar to me or
sounds familiar um anyway putting that
aside the numbers are right there you
saw the numbers about 800 000 new people
here in Florida and I think that's on
the low end of it and as you know about
1200 people move here a day and when I
interviewed Governor DeSantis last week
he talked about how one of the things
that we're going to have to do here in
Florida is escalate building projects
because we want people to have
affordable housing we want there to be
roads so there isn't all the congestion
and everything else but isn't it
interesting they only frame that about
money they somehow didn't mention
anything about all of the crime and the
rampant riots and the BLM antifa stuff
and that where I lived in Los Angeles
which was an extremely nice area that
the entire Ventura Boulevard was
basically burned down and defunct and
devoid or that San Francisco has become
a zombie apocalypse because of Fentanyl
and meth somehow none of those things
it's just these people they just want
bigger houses guys how that happened
they all decided that during covet I
guess which was pretty bizarre uh but
you guys see it the proof is in the
pudding with all of these things and uh
yeah where are people going well it's
not just that they're moving down here
they're also vacationing down here like
my parents last week Rod DeSantis
tweeted this out
Florida broke our visitation record with
more than
137.6 million visitors in 2022 and this
was in spite of the Biden
administration's unscientific vax
mandate for overseas Travelers let us
all not forget of course I went into my
British accent again of the guy reading
New York Times let us all not forget
that also AOC and several other
Progressive politicians vacationed in
Florida while they were locking their
own people at home because they're good
liberals you know uh Governor DeSantis
who is doing this blueprint situation
right he is Blueprinting for the rest of
the country
how to fix all of this because we have
done it so right here and that's what we
have needed how do you fix it at the
state level and then export that that's
what his book is about the courage
should be free which came out last week
I think they'll find out tomorrow if
it's number one on New York Times list
but New York Times is all horseshit
anyway it doesn't really matter so it'll
be kind of funny either way either they
have to do it because it'll be so
obvious or they don't do it in which
case he can expose them for it kind of
beautiful anyway he is making the rounds
and he was in California over the
weekend here he is at the Reagan Library
just laying down some truth
[Applause]
I know you guys got a lot of problems
out here but your Governor is very
concerned about what we're doing in
Florida so I figured I had to come by
yeah and then you know what he did you
know what he did he laid out policies
that could fix California I have no
doubt that California will not go for
those policies they rejected the recall
they they re-elected Gavin Newsom who I
believe is a lizard person from another
planet I do not mean that as a joke
something is not right there I believe
he is a cold-blooded lizard wearing a
human skin outfit
um and they re-elected him by a
landslide so so be it California but
DeSantis is right he continued in the
speech talking about how people know
it's right here and that's what we have
to show them and get more of them to
support
if someone like you were to run for
president could this be done on a
national level
so I think all the ideas uh that we talk
about in the book and the successes we
have I do think there's a majority of
the American people uh that would
support it I mean you think about it
Florida has been a microcosm of the
country for a long time you know we're
winning places like Miami-Dade County
you know that's going to bode well for
for other parts of the country now if
you talk about at the federal level
there are certain things that may be
easier actually to do because I think
that with the vast administrative state
if you have a determined executive uh
who knows how to use those levers of
power I think you could do a complete
upheaval of the deep state
I believe it too I believe it too and I
think you believe it but now it's going
to take something else right because
we're constantly swimming swimming
Upstream right the machine the culture
wars The Comedians like the whole thing
we're always swimming against it in an
off election year uh you know there
should have been a red wave there wasn't
we have to accept that whether it's
ballot harvesting or a brunt a bunch of
brainwashed people we have to accept
that we're fighting something that we we
don't automatically win but there are
ways to win and that's why the state by
state blueprint that I think DeSantis is
laying out is the best way to go about
doing this not just these crazy sweeping
statements like I'm gonna upend
everything and save everything like
proof in the pudding kind of stuff that
is happening here at our hyper
functional free state of Florida but it
continues because this weekend was also
CPAC and CPAC is obviously the big
conservative uh conference that they do
every year it doesn't seem like it has
the the zest or maybe the energy that
it's had in years past but Lee zeldin
was there Lee zeldon of course you guys
know he was the congressman from New
York work who almost pulled off the
craziest upset ever in New York DeSantis
was pulling for him at a massive massive
rally just days before the election
oddly hocho had no rallies right there
were no rallies but somehow they win so
again you gotta You Gotta Give the devil
his do like we can just make fun of them
all day but somehow these people win and
they stay in power and they do horrible
things to their citizens and their
citizens say thank you sir may I have
another but Lee zeldin at CPAC was
talking about how conservatives good
decent conservatives and good decent
liberals and remember there still are
some and we got to find them how if we
could freaking out create an alliance
between these two people we could stop
the leftist whack jobs watch this
a little bit about that well we need to
be competing everywhere in all 50 states
I don't care what state you come from
there are important races especially
down ballot and we saw instead of New
York sending six Republicans as part of
our delegation to D.C we ended up
sending 11. we end up flipping control
of the House of Representatives Nancy
Pelosi is no longer speaker we need to
go into Democratic areas and the best
way to get Democrat votes is not to act
like Democrats but to explain why we are
proud principled conservatives and don't
Pander if you go speak to a black group
or a Hispanic group or an Asian Vote or
Jewish group don't say I love black
people vote for me I love Asian people
vote for me I love Hispanic people vote
for me say we need to improve safety on
these streets here is how these are our
proposals we need to improve the quality
of Education inside of your kids schools
here's how these Democrats are unhappy
with the Democratic policies and the
Democratic party as a whole but they
aren't going to just swing to the
Republicans on their own it's a bad
assumption that we are making instead
what we need to do is to show up over
and over and over again when your high
paid political consultant tells you not
to go to a heavily Democratic area
that's exactly where we need to show up
and earn the support of these Democrats
we cannot relinquish the cities we
cannot relinquish the suburbs okay
there's a lot there that I agree with I
want to just I'll do the one thing that
I maybe slightly disagree with which is
the cities I just think the cities are
so out of whack
the Machinery of let's say a New York
and a San Francisco it is so entrenched
in everything I don't know that the
cities can be saved but the States can
be saved right and good decent liberals
who will flee those cities and they're
already fleeing those cities they can be
uh approached they can be talked to this
is what I I don't know anyone that has
done the ex-lib thing uh more
effectively than me I don't mean it as a
pat on my back I mean it's just this is
what I was freaking doing and here we
are right but he is right you go to
those places
you go to those places and you say um
you remember when you're when your town
wasn't overrun with crime and drugs and
you're upset because you know your kids
hooked on fentanyl you may not realize
this but this has something to do with
the policies of the Democrats who've let
the Border be poorest so these people
could come in with drugs and if you can
make that connection the person who has
the kid who's on drugs might go okay I
can't vote for people who are for in
essence open borders anymore and if you
go well wait a minute why is it that the
crime is so high and then and they're
because they don't want high crime
obviously and they go wait a minute it
is true that my local representative say
in Minneapolis ilhan Omar was screaming
about defunding the police for two years
but then we did it and murder went up by
something like 400 percent if we can
connect these ideas but then as he said
at the end it doesn't mean that they're
going to vote Republican until you make
a case for yourself that is the case
that DeSantis has made here and that's
why he won by 20 points so guys we have
we have everything we need right in
front of us we just got to keep going
and I would say a in summation this is
the longest show we've ever done and if
I dare say so myself it's been pretty
solid despite that screw-up 81 minutes
ago 82 minutes Jesus
um one final thing is it's not just that
we have to fix this politically we
obviously do we have to keep breaking
the machine and everything else but we
also must build new things at Russell
Brand who we started with about an hour
and 20 ago was also on Joe Rogan talking
about how the more the sensorious
machine gets the more sensorious the
machine gets the more that it will allow
for alternative things to rise and uh
yes I agree
controversial because we never we never
change but they they do things to
get people to self-censor of course and
Rumble doesn't do that it was that well
yeah exactly what was difficult for us
when we were when YouTube was at primary
platform is something we would look at
your content all right that's the title
of this Rogan video on this is the
content okay well we can try that and
then we would get demonetized and it
becomes like a weird algebra you change
this word you change that word you have
to order it you have there's certain
things you just and you know that you
can't say and you still get some money
from like YouTube Red yeah you still get
but it was like they were doing things
and I mean they were running a business
I understand from their perspective of
course you know they're running a
business they have advertisers I
understand from their perspective but
from a Content creation perspective
you just couldn't trust them this is
what uh Rumble of fundamentally offered
they gave me a good deal and the
Assurance That We're Not Gonna censor
you now obviously coming from where I
come from politically and in terms of my
background even as a person that's been
in the public for a while I'm like I
know how rumble's being portrayed it's
being portrayed as a right wing like
we're getting far right place conspiracy
theorist yeah you and Glenn Greenwald
super far right yes like this married
gay Pulitzer Prize winning I'm a
journalist Tulsi gabbard super right
word yes like it's nuts it's nuts what
people call it it's just anything
alternative to the censorship model
they'll talk of as right wing so you
guys get it you will always be framed as
a right-wing maniac and any new product
that comes in and is effective will be
framed as four right-wing crazy people
or buy right-wing crazy people or
anything else but I would much rather be
with the right wing crazies who actually
aren't that crazy then the leftist
lunatics who have set this entire game
up so that everything that we all hold
dear and precious will be destroyed
that ladies and gentlemen is our longest
show in the history of the Reuben report
I have to pee to be quite honest but I'm
not going to take a break we are going
to roll right into the post game show in
just a moment we've got a oh wait it's
me Monday let's show the me Monday
before we do anything that's my me
Monday for today Lori Lightfoot got a
new job very very exciting and you can
see how excited the customer is so that
is pretty pretty great you can join us
at reubenreport.locals.com if you want
to play on me Monday and also the post
game show will be there right now we'll
take comments questions did I screw
anything up please let me know uh we
leave you oh my full episode if you
haven't seen it yet with Peter Thiel
just went up yesterday the clips had
been up earlier so if you want to check
that out it's up across platforms we
leave you with AOC drag queen blah blah
blah blah blah and I will see everybody
in about 41 seconds adios
every night I would come home and the
only thing that would help me disconnect
and unplugged was watching drag race wow
that was that was the thing that I did
every single night and to be in this
moment is just so humbling and amazing
and I'm just trying to drink it up the
way you all are it's just so crazy that
like somebody's so important in this
country would take the time out of their
life to come here not only you being
here but to hear that you love and
appreciate what we do and that it helps
affect change throughout the Universe
and like hearing that from you who is so
you know amazingly powerful and
impactful to our society right now and
I'm so appreciative I know everybody
here is too so thank you like we are
literally gag that you're sitting right
here
[Music]
thank you